Yes My name is Yahshua Benji two and I'm a professor here at the university Montreal.
I also lead an institute called the Montreal in situ programming on things that is specializing in my area of science
which is machine learning how computers learn from examples. Yes. Right. Yes so deep.
Learning is inside the machine learning is one of the approaches to to machine learning.
Machine earning is very general it's about learning from examples
and scientist over the last few decades after pose many approaches for allowing computers to learn from examples deep
learning is.
Introducing a particular notion that the computer learns to represent information
and to do so at multiple levels of distraction. What I'm saying is a bit abstract but to make it easier.
I could say that the planning is also heavily inspired by what we know of the brain of Hondurans compute.
And it's a follow up on they Cade's of earlier work on what's called neural networks or artificial neural networks so.
What. I got interested in networks.
And machine learning right at the beginning of migrated study so
when I was doing my master's I was looking for a subject
and I started reading some of these papers on neural networks and these
and this was the early days of the sickle connectionist movement and I got really really excited
and I started learning more and I told the professor who was going to supervise me that this is what I want.
Do and and that's what I did and I continue doing it and I'm still doing it. With. Someone.
So say it's funny that you ask this question because it depends.
It's like some days I feel very clearly that I know where I'm going.
And I can see very far I have the impression that I'm seeing far in the future
and I see also where I've been it's there's there's a very clear path and sometimes may you get more discouraged
and I feel. Where am I going. It's only exploration I don't know where the future or what the future holds. Of course.
So I go between these two states which I don't. I mean right now I'm pretty positive about a particular direction.
I moved to some fundamental questions that I find really exciting and that's kind of driving a lot of my thinking.
And looking forward. So. Right. So.
My main quest is to understand the principles that underlie intelligence
and I believe this happens through learning that intelligent behavior arises in nature and in.
The computers that we're building through learning the machine the animal the human becomes intelligent because it
learns.
And understanding the underlying principles is like and are standing the laws of aerodynamics for building airplanes
and so I and others in my field or trying to figure out where is the equivalent of the laws of I read aerodynamics
but for intelligence. So that's that's the quests and we're taking inspiration from brains.
We're taking inspiration from a lot of our experiments that we're doing with computers trying to learn from data.
We're taking inspiration from. Other disciplines from physics from. Psychology and neuroscience and other fields.
Even you know. And it trickle engineering and of course it does the I mean it's very multi-disciplinary area. Yes I do.
So one of the.
Well may not be so easy to explain
but one of the big mysteries about how brains manage to do what they do is what scientists have called for many decades
the question of credit assignment that is hollow do neurons in the middle of your brain hidden somewhere get to know
how they should change what they should be doing that would be useful for the whole collective but that is the brain
and. We don't know how brains do it. We now have algorithms that do a pretty good job at it.
They have their limitations.
But one of the things I'm trying to do is to better understand this this credit assignment.
QUESTION And it's crucial for the planning because the planning is about having many levels of neurons talking to each
other.
So that's what we call them deep there are many layers of neurons and that's what gives them their power
but the challenge is how do we train them how do they learn and it gets harder.
The more layers you have so in the eighty's people found how to train networks with a single hidden layer.
So just not very deep.
But they were already able to do interesting things
and about ten years ago we started discovering ways to train much deeper networks
and that's what led to this current revolution called deep learning. And. So forth.
Yes So in the world of artificial intelligence. There's been a big shift. Brought by the planning.
So there's been some scientific advances
but then it turned into advances in applications so very quickly these techniques turned out to be very useful for
improving how computers understand speech for example that speech recognition
and then later much bigger would say in terms of impact effect happened
when we discovered that these algorithms could be very good for object recognition from images
and now many other tasks in computer vision are being done using these kinds of networks these deep networks earn.
Some specialized version of the networks called convolution networks that work we do well for images and and then it.
It moves on.
So now people who are doing a lot of work on natural language trying to have the computer understand English sentences.
What you need. In being able to answer some questions and so on.
So these are applications but they have a huge economy impact
and even more in the future so that has attracted a lot of attention from from other scientists from the media
and from of course businesspeople who are investing billions of dollars in this right now.
It is it is very exciting and it's not something I really expected because ten years ago
when we started working on this. There were very few people in the world.
Maybe a handful of people interested in these questions.
And initially it started very slowly we was difficult to to to get money for these kinds of things.
It was difficult to convince students to work on these kinds of things. Yes. Right that's right that's right.
Yes that's right.
So there has been a decade before the last day Cade where these kind of research Senshi went out of fashion people
moved on to other interests the last mission to actually get AI to get machines to be as intelligent as us
and also the connection between neuroscience and machine earning.
It got a big divorce but a few people including myself and Geoff Henton and yellow care.
Continue doing this and we started to have the results.
And other people can you know in the world who are also doing this and more people joined us
and in a matter of odd five years. It started to be a more accepted area and then and. In the.
Applications the success and application is starting to happen. And now it's crazy. I mean.
We get hundreds of applicants for example for doing studies here and. Companies are hiring like crazy and and.
And buying scientists for their research labs. Yeah yeah yeah. Yes yes. So I could be much richer.
But I chose to stay in academia. So you make. Yes yes very valuable. Yes.
Basically it's at the heart of what companies like Google Microsoft I.B.M. Facebook sun so on.
Azzam on Twitter all of these companies they these see this as the key a key technology for their future products
and some of the existing products already already. Right now. They are of course I don't have a crystal ball.
So there are a lot of research questions which remain.
And some of that might take just a couple of years or decades to solve and we don't know
but even if say scientific research on topic stop right now.
And you took the current state of the art in terms of the science and you just applied it right.
Collecting the lots of data sets and two to two because these albums need a lot of data.
Applying the current science would already have a huge impact on society. So so they're not.
I don't think they're making a very risky bet.
But it could be even better because we could we could actually approach human level intelligence.
We could I think that will we'll have other.
Other challenges to deal with that
and some of them we currently know are in front of us others we probably will discover when we get there so exciting.
Yeah. Oh yeah oh yes yes it's true it's true son. So initially it's exhilarating to have all this attention.
And it's grad to great to have all this recognition and
and also it's great to track need you know best minds that are coming here for doing Ph D.'s
and things like that it's it's it's absolutely great.
But sometimes I feel that it's been too much and that I don't deserve that much attention
and all this all these interactions with the media and so on are taking time away from my research.
And so it's you know I have to find the right balance here.
I think it is really important to continue to explain what we're doing so that more people can learn about it
and take advantage of it or become researchers themselves in this area.
But I need to also focus on my main strength which is not speaking to Jonas my main strength is to come up with new
ideas crazy schemes and you know interacting with students to to build new things. Real.
Well of course science is an exploration. And I'm I'm often wrong.
I proposed ten things one of which end up not working. But but we make progress so.
I get frequent positive feedback that they'll need we're moving in the right direction.
Yes Yes Yes And these days because the number of people working on this is grown really fast the rate at which advances
come. Is incredible.
The speed of progress in this field as drapery accelerated and mostly because there are more people doing it.
Yes So companies are investing a lot in basic research in this field which is an unusual way.
Typically companies would invest in Applied Research where you take existing algorithms
and try to make them use them for products but right now there's a big war between these big I.T.
Companies to attract talent and also the understand that there is the.
Potential impact the potential benefit of future research is probably even greater than what we over really achieved.
So for these two reasons they have invested a lot in basic research and they are as you can be making offers to.
Professors and students in the field to come work with them.
In an environment that looks a little bit like what you have in universities where they have a lot of freedom they can
publish they can go to conferences and talk with their peers.
So so it's a it's a good time for the progress of science because companies are working in the same direction as
universities towards really fundamental questions.
So that's something that's one of the reasons why they
and I can e-mail want to make sure that what I do is going to be.
Not owned by a particular person but the vailable for anyone. Well.
I don't I don't think it's I don't think it's a big deal right now.
So the major research industrial research centers they publish a lot of what they do. And they have.
They do half patents but they say that these patents are protective so in case somebody would sue them
but they won't prevent other people other companies who you're seeing there technology that's what they say.
And so right now. There is a lot of openness in and in the business environment for for this field.
We'll see how things are in the future and there's always a danger of companies.
Coming to a point where the become protective and
but then what I think is that companies who pull themselves out of the community and not participate.
To the scientific progress and exchange with the others they will not progress as fast
and I think that's the reason why do they understand that if they want to receive the most benefits from this progress.
They have to be part of the public. Again. You know exchanging information and not keeping information secret.
Yes exactly.
Part of the collective that we are building of all our ideas and our understanding of the world
and there is something about doing it.
Part speaking to it that enables us to be more powerful in understanding if we're just trying to be consumers of ideas
we're not mastering those ideas as well as if we're actually trying to improvement improve them.
So when we do research.
We we get on top of things much more than if we're simply trying to understand some existing paper
and trying to use it for its own product.
So there is something that is strongly he and the billing for companies to do that kind of the. But that's new. It's.
One decay to go for example.
Many companies were shutting down their research labs and so on so that was it was a different spirit.
But right now the spirit is openness sharing and participating in the sort of common.
Development of ideas through science and. And publication and so on. Yes yes yes. Oh boy. Well I think it.
First of all it's appealing. I mean as a person.
If I'm a researcher as a Ph D.'s candidate or a professor or something.
It's much more appealing to me to know that what I do will be a contribution to humanity right rather than something
secret only I and a few people know about and maybe some people make a lot of money out of it that.
I don't think it's as satisfying. And as I said I think there are circumstances right now and that.
Even from purely an economy point of view it's more interesting for companies to share right now.
And be part of the of the research. So. You know. Yes. What. Yes is. Right.
Well obviously we don't know because the brain is still we don't know how to brain works.
You have a lot of information about it. Too much. Maybe.
But not enough of the kind that allows us to figure out the basic principles of how.
How we think and what does it mean at a very abstract level but of course I have my own understanding.
So I can share that. And with the kinds of questions I draw on the board there. In other people in my field.
There is the notion that what thinking is about is adjusting your mental configuration.
To be more coherent more consistent with everything you've observed right and more typically.
The things you are thinking about or what you are currently observing.
So if I observe a picture mine your own as change their state to be in agreement with the picture and in agreement.
Given everything that the brain already knows means that they are looking for an interpretation for that image. Would.
Maybe related to things they could do that are related. Like maybe oh I see this.
I need to go there because it tells me a message that's matters to me.
So everything we know is somehow built in this internal model of the world that our brain hands and.
And we get all these pieces of evidence each time we hear something something we listen something
and our brain is actually moving all that stuff
and then what it does is try to make sense of it all the piece like a piece of a puzzle.
And so sometimes you know it happens to you eat something clicks right.
Suddenly you see a connection that explains different things.
Your brain does that all the time not always that you get it.
This conscious impression and and thinking is is this according to me it's. It's it's. Finding.
Structure and meaning and the things that we are observing and that we've seen
and that's also what science does right science is about finding explanations for what is around us.
But thinking is happening in our head where science is a is a is a social thing. It's.
Science the science has a part inside science as a part inside of course because we are thinking when we do science
but science has a social aspect science is a community of minds working together in the history of minds having you
know discovered. Concepts that explain the world around us and sharing that in ways that are efficient.
But one thing I could talk about too is learning or I need money of us. Thank you.
But I think a very modern concept in my area is learning.
I think I can explain what that how that can happen in in those models or brains. We hear today. I think you know.
You would like to know what. That's good question. I don't think that there's a consensus on that either.
But on what is intelligence. My question.
OK OK OK So what is intelligence that's that's a good question and I don't think that there's a consensus
but in my area of research. People generally understand intelligence is the ability to take good decisions.
And what good decisions like good for me right.
Good in the sense that they allow me to achieve my goals too if I was an animal to survive my predator is to find food
to find mates and for humans good might be achieving social status or being happy
or whatever you know it's in your mind what is your.
What is it that's good for you but but somehow we are striving to take decisions that are good for us.
And in order to do that. It's very clear. Or that we need some form of knowledge so. Even a mouse.
That's choosing to go left or right in a maze is using knowledge and.
That kind of knowledge is not necessarily the kind of knowledge you find in a book right.
The mouse cannot read a book couldn't write a book but in the mouse's brain. There is knowledge about how to.
How to control the mouse body in order to survive to find food and so on.
So the mouse is actually very intelligent in the context of the life of a mouse.
If you were soley for the border going there in the mouse you would probably find it difficult to do the right things.
So intelligence about taking right decision and it requires knowledge
and now the question is to build intelligent machines or to understand how humans and animals are intelligent.
Where are we getting the knowledge.
Where can we get the knowledge and some of it is hard wired in your brain from you from birth.
And some of it is going to be learned through experience and that's the thing that we're studying in my field.
How do we learn.
Or rather what are they mathematical principles for learning that could be applied to computers
and not just trying to figure out what animals how animals learn. Right.
So yes my definition of learning is not the kind of learning that people think about when they are in school
and listening to a teacher. Learning some. And we do all the time.
Our brain is changing all the time in response to what we are seeing experiencing and it's an adaptation
and we're not just. Storing in our brain our experiences. It's not learning by heart. That's easy.
A file in a computer is lower is like learning by heart. You can store facts.
But that's trivial That's not what learning really is about learning is about integrating the information we're getting
through experience into some more abstract form that allows us to take good decisions that allow us to predict what
will happen next. Allow us to understand the connections between things we've seen.
So that's what learning is really about in my field we talk about the notion of generalization so that the machine can
generalize from things it has seen and learned from to new situations.
That's the kind of learning we talk about in my field and the way we typically do it in machines
and how we think it's happening in the brain is that it's it's a slow dreidel process each time you live an experience
one second of your life. There's going to be some changes in your brain small changes.
So it's like you or your whole system is drudgery shifting towards. What would make it take better decisions.
So that's how you get to be intelligent right because you learn. Meaning you change the way you perceive and act.
So that next time you would see something you would have some experience similar to what happened before you would act
better or you would predict better what would have happened. Yes.
Learning is completely experience based of course in school we think of learning as teaching knowledge from a book
or some. Blackboard. But that's not really the main kind of learning.
There is some learning happening when we when the student integrates all that information
and tries to make sense of it but just storing those facts is kind of useless.
Well motivation for humans is very important because we're wired like this
and the reason we're wired like this is there are so many things happening around us.
That emotions help us to filter and focus on some aspects more than others.
Those that matter to us right and some motivation might be fear as well and times are bad for computers.
Basically they will learn what we ask them to learn.
We don't need to introduce vision or emotions these up to now we haven't needed to do that. When you say yes yes.
There's. Where you can you can. Emotions are something we're born with we were bone with born with.
Circuits that make us experience emotions because. Some situations matter more to us. So in the case of the computer.
We we also in a sense hardwired these things by telling the computer.
Well this matters more than that and you have to learn to predict. Well here and here and. Is less.
So we don't call that emotions but it could play a similar role. Right. Absolutely. So AI is completely programmed.
OK so there's an interesting connection between learning
and programming so the traditional way of putting knowledge into computers is to write a program that essentially
contains all our our knowledge in step by step.
We tell the computer if this happens you do this and then you do that and then you do that
and then this happens you know that. And so on and so on.
That's what a program is but when we allow the computer to learn.
We also program it but the program that is there is different.
It's not a program that contains the knowledge we want to computer to have we don't program the computer with the
knowledge of doors and cars and images and sounds you program the computer with the ability to learn
and then the computer experiences.
You know images or videos or sounds or texts and learns the knowledge from those experiences.
So you can think of the learning program as a made up program and we have something like that in our brain.
So if one part of the cortex dies you have an accident.
That part used to be doing some job like may be dealing interpreting music your some some types of songs or something.
Well if you continue listening to music then some other part will take over.
And that function may have been sort of and impaired for some time
but then it will be taken by some other part of your cortex. What does that mean it means that the same.
The does the learning was there in those two regions of the cortex the one that used to be the doing the job
and the one does it now. And that means that your brain has the same general purpose learning. Recipient.
That it can apply to different problems
and that the different parts of your brain will be specialized on different tasks depending on what you do in which how
the brain is connected.
If if if we remove that part of your brain then some other parts will start doing the job if the job is needed because
you expose you to those experiences right.
So if I had a part of my brain that was essentially dealing with playing tennis and you know that part dies.
I'm not going to be able to play tennis anymore.
But if I continue practicing it's going to come back
and that means that the same learning general purpose learning recipient is used everywhere at least in cortex
and this is important not just for for understanding brains
but for companies building products because we have this general purpose receive the.
Or family of recipients that can be applied for many tasks.
The only thing that really differs between those different task is the data the examples of the computer sees so that's
why companies are so excited about this because they can use this for many problems that they want to solve so long as
they can teach the machine by showing it. Examples.
Learning is positive by construction in the sense that it's moving the learner towards a state of understanding of its
experiences. So in general yes because. Learning is about improving something.
Now if the something you're improving is not the thing you should be improving. Then you could be in trouble.
You could learn.
People could be trained into wrong understanding of the world and then they start doing bad things right.
So that's why education is so important for humans
and for machines right now the things we're asking the machines to do is are very simple like
and are standing the content of images and text and videos and things like that. Why.
But if you're just observing things around you.
They can run a million then it's just what the world is right there right now.
Yeah the learning that computers do is very primitive it's it's mostly about perception and the case of language.
Some kind of semantic understanding but it's still a pretty low level understanding. Was.
So the way that the computer is learning is by small. Interactive changes right so.
So let's go back to my artificial neural network which is a bunch of neurons connected to each other
and they are connected through these these synaptic connections
and I each of these connections there is the strength of the connection which controls how your own influences Nabhan
your own. So you can think of that strength as a knob. And what happens during learning is those knobs change.
We don't know how they change in the brain but in our algorithms we know how they change
and we understand mathematically why it makes sense to do that
and they change a little bit each time you see an example. So I show the image.
The cat but the computer says it's a dog.
So I'm going to change those knobs so that it's going to be more likely that the computer is going to say cat.
Maybe the computer outputs a score for a dog and a score for a cat
and so what we want to do is decrease the score for for dog and increase the score for cat so that the computer.
Eventually after seeing many millions of images starts.
Seeing the right class more often and eventually gets it as well as humans. Do something. How do you know. You know.
Well you can test it on new images right so if the computer was only learning by heart.
Copying the examples that it has seen.
It wouldn't be able to recognize a new image of say new breed of dog or a new angle new lighting
and level of pixels those images could be very very different. But if the computer really figured.
Katniss at least from the point of view of images.
It will be able to recognize new images of new cats taken a new postures and so on
and that's what we call July zation So we do it.
Al the time we test the computer to see if it can generalize to new examples new images new sentences.
Oh yeah yeah yeah I'll try to show you some some examples of that. So. Right now. Yes OK let me.
Oh I thought this was a a statement not a question. Well but yes of course there are many things that you're missing.
So there are many many interesting questions in the planning but one of the.
Interesting challenges has to do with the question of supervised learning versus unsupervised learning.
Right now the way we teach the machine to do things
or to recognize things is we use what's called supervised learning where we tell the computer exactly what it should do.
Or what output it should have. For a given input.
So that's a I showing of the image of a cat again I tell the computer. This is a cat and I have to show it.
Millions of such images.
That's not the way humans learn to see and understand the world or even understand language for the most part we just.
Make sense of what we observe without having a teacher that is sitting. By us and telling us every second of our life.
This is a cow. This is the dog that's right there is no supervisor and we do get some feedback but it's pretty rare.
And sometimes it's only implicit so.
You you do something and you get you get a reward
but you don't know exactly what it was you did that you knew that we weren't
or you get a you know we talked to somebody.
The person is unhappy and you're not sure exactly what you did that was wrong and the person is not going tell you.
General what you should have done.
So this is called reinforcement learning where you get some feedback but it's a very weak.
You know you did well or you didn't do well. Like you have an exam and you you. You know sixty five percent.
Well you don't know if you don't know what the errors were
and what the right answers are it's very difficult to learn from that
but we we are able to learn from that from very weak signals or know you know when Foresman of all known
or feedback just by observation and trying to make sense of all of these pieces of information that's called
and spoke lies money. And we we're not yet.
We're much more advanced with supervised learning than with unsurprising So all of the products that these companies
are building right now is mostly based on supervised learning. So yes yes.
That means the computer will be more autonomy in some sense that we don't need more autonomy it's right.
Well more autonomous in its learning.
Yes We're not talking about robots here
and we're just talking about computers gradually making sense of the world around us by observation and.
We probably will still need to give them some guidance
but the question is how much guidance right now we have to give them a lot of guidance if you have to tell everything.
Very precisely for then.
So we're trying to move away from that so that they can essentially become more intelligent because they can take
advantage of all of the information out there which isn't doesn't come with a human that explains every bit in bits
and pieces but yes. Sure. It's often it's just a program running.
And stored in files there is nothing like there's no robot. There's no I mean at least in the work we do.
It's just a program that contains files that are like the contains the in those synaptic weights for example.
And as we see more examples we change those files so that they will correspond to taking the right decisions
but there's no. Those computers don't have a consciousness. There's no such thing right now at least. For a while.
So so yeah. Autonomy is in its learning right. Yes.
Well I gain is probably going to be a gradual thing where the computer requires less and less of our guidance
but we probably so if you think about humans we still need guidance. If you take a human. And.
A baby a few nobody wants and that experiment you can imagine a baby being isolated from society.
That child probably would not grow to be very intelligent would not understand the world around us as well as we do.
That's because we've had parents teachers and so on guided us. And we been immersed in culture.
So all that matters and it.
It's possible that it will also be required for computers to reach our level of intelligence the same kind of attention
we're giving to humans we might need to give to computers
but right now the amount of attention we have to give to computers for them to learn about very simple things is much
larger than what we need to give to humans. Humans are much more autonomy and they're learning.
Then machines are right now. So we have a lot of progress to do in that direction.
Well biology is not magical biology is can be understood.
It's what biologists are trying to do and we understand a lot
but they're as far as the brain is concerned there's the big holes in the arm standing.
So yes sure it can I mean we can we can give it more memory and so on.
Right so that you can you can grow the size of the model. That's not a big obstacle.
I mean computing power is an obstacle but I'm pretty confident that over the next few years we're going to see.
More and more computing power available as it has been in the past.
That will make it more possible to train models to do more complex tasks. So how do you do. Right right. Now.
So I think that's right. I do I do. So first of all I think there is being a bit of excessive expression of fear.
About EON maybe because the progress has been so fast and it has made us some people worried
but if you ask people like me who are into it every day.
They're not worried because they can see how stupid the machines are right now.
And how much guidance they need to do to move forward. So it was it looks like we're very far from.
I'm human level intelligence and even you know I have no idea whether one day computers will be smarter than us.
Now that may be a short term view what will happen in the future is hard to say.
But we can we can think about it and I think it's good that some people are thinking about the potential dangers.
I think it's difficult right now to have a grasp on how what could go wrong
but with the kind of intelligence that we're building in machines right now I'm not very worried the there it's not the
kind of intelligence that I could for see. Exploding becoming more and more intelligent by itself.
I don't think that's plausible for the kinds of like people earning methods and so on.
Even if they were much more powerful and it's not something I can envision. That being said.
It's good that there are people who are thinking about these long term issues one thing I'm more worried about is the
use of technology.
Now or in the next couple of years or five or ten years where the technology could be developed
and used in a way that could either be very good for many people or not so good for many people.
So for example military use and.
Other uses which I think I would consider not a proper iot are things we need to worry about. Yeah.
So so so there's been a fuss
and a letter signed by a number of scientists who try to tell the world we should have a ban on.
The use of AI for autonomy as weapons that could essentially take the decision to kill by themselves.
So that's something that's not very far fetched in terms of technology in the given science. Basically the.
The science is there is a matter of building these things.
But it's not something we would like to see in
and there could be an arms race of these things so we need to prevent it. The same way that collectively.
The nations decided to have bans on biological weapons and chemical weapons
and to some extent on nuclear weapons the same thing should be done for that.
And then there are other uses of the technology as especially as it matures which I think are questionable from an
ethical point of view.
So I think that the use of these technologies to convince you to do things like with publicity and trying to influence.
Maybe think about influencing your vote right.
As the knowledge
and becomes really stronger you could imagine people essentially using this technology to money probably you in ways
you don't realize is good for them but it's not good for you.
And I think we have to start be aware of that and all these issues of privacy are connected as well but
but in general because we're training currently companies are using these systems for advertisements where they trying
to predict are what they should show you. So that you will be more likely to buy some product right.
So it seems you know not saw bad but if you push it.
You know he they might bring you into doing things that are not so good for you. I don't know the smoking or whatever.
Right. Stop. OK. What. That. What I will elaborate now. So you're asking me about diversity.
And I can say several things first of all people who are not aware of the kinds of things we bring in any eye with
machine learning the planning and so on may not realize the the algorithms the methods we're using already.
Include a lot of what may look like diversity creativity.
So for the same input the computer could produce different answers
and so there's a bit of randomness just like for us place twice in the same situation.
We don't always take the same decision and there are good reasons for that both for us and for computers.
So that's the first part of it
but there is another aspect of the versity which I have studied in the paper a few years ago which is may be even more
interesting. Diversity is very important for example for evolution to succeed.
Because evolution performs a kind of search in the space of genomes of the blueprint of each individuals.
And machine running is considered what happens in a single individual we learn. How our machine can learn but has not.
Really investigated much the role of having a group of individuals learning together. So a kind of society.
And in this paper a few years ago I postulated that. Learning in an individual could get stuck that.
If we were alone learning by observing the world around us we might get stuck with poor model of the world.
And we get unstuck by talking to other people and by learning from other people in the sense of.
They can communicate some of the ideas the have how the interpret the world. And that's what culture is about.
Culture has many meanings but that's the meaning that I have that it's the not just the actual nation of knowledge
but but how knowledge gets created through communication and sharing
and what I postulated in that paper is that there is a it's good enough to make zation problem that can get the
learning of an individual.
To not progress any more in a sense that as I said before learning is a lot of small changes
but sometimes there is no small change that we makes you progress.
So you need some kind of external kick that brings a new light to things.
And another connection to evolution of the connection to evolution actually is that this this market we get from others
is like you're building on top of existing solutions that others have come up with
and of course the process of science is very much like this rebuilding of other scientists ideas
but it's true for culture in general
and this actually makes the whole process of building more intelligent beings much more efficient in.
Fact we know that since humans have made progress.
Thanks to evolution and not just thanks to culture and not just to evolution.
We've been making our intelligence has been increasing much faster. So it will Lucian. Is slow.
Whereas you can think of culture.
The evolution of culture as a process that's much more efficient because we are many believing the right objects.
So what does this mean in practice it means that.
Just like evolution needs the versity to succeed because there are many different.
Variants of the same type of genes that are.
Randomly chosen and tried
and the best ones combined together to create new solutions just like this in cultural evolution which is really a
portent.
Important for intelligence that was saying we need diversity we need not just one school of thought we need to allow
all kinds of exploration. Most of which may fail.
So in science we need to be open to new ideas even it's very likely it's not going to work.
It's good that people explore. Otherwise we're going to get stuck in some.
In the space of possible interpretations of the world may take forever before we escape. Yes that's right.
So basic research is exploratory it's not trying to build a product.
It's just trying to understand and it's going in all possible directions.
According to our intuitions of you know what may be more interesting but but without a strong constraint.
So yeah basic research is like this but
but there is a danger because humans are the the life you know fashionable things.
And trends and compare each other and so on that.
That we are we're not giving enough freedom for exploration and it's not just science in general
and society we should allow a lot more freedom we should allow marginal ways of being and doing things to to co-exist.
Which is.
Well it's a gamble
and eye on the positive side I think that the rewards we can get by having more intelligence machines is immense
and the way I think about it is it's not a competition between machines and humans.
Technology is is expanding what we are.
Thanks to technology we are now already much stronger and more intelligent than we were the same way that.
Dusty revolution as kind of increased our strength
and our ability to do things physically the sort of computer revolution
and now the IANA evolution is going to increase continue to increase are coming to abilities. Right.
But I think we should be conscious that a lot of that fear is due to a projection into things we are familiar with.
So we're thinking of a I like We think like we see them in movies where think of AI like we see.
Some kind of alien from another planet like we see animals
when we think of about another being we think that other being is like us. And so we are a greedy.
We want to dominate the rests. If our survival is at stake. We're ready to kill right.
So we project that some machine is going to be just like us.
And if that machine is more powerful than we are then we are deep trouble right.
So it's just because we are making that projection but actually the machines are not some being it's house and ego
and the survival instinct. It's actually something we decide to put together as a program.
And so we should be smart enough and wise enough to program these machines. To be useful to us rather than.
Go towards their own needs. They will cater to our needs because we will design them that way. So. Yes.
Maybe maybe not. I don't that's not the way I say it.
What you're saying is appealing if I was read a science fiction book but it doesn't correspond to how I see a I
and the kinds of AI we're doing.
I don't see such acceleration fact what I see is the opposite of what I foresee is more like barriers than acceleration
so. Yes So our experience in research.
Is that we make progress
and then we encounter a barrier a difficult challenge a difficulty that the algorithm goes so far
and then you can't make progress. Even if you have more compute power.
That's not really the issue the issue are more are basically computer science issues that things get harder as you try
to solve exponentially harder really much much harder as you try to solve more complex problems.
So it's actually the opposite.
I think that happens that
and I think that would also explain maybe to some extent why we're not super intelligent ourselves I mean the sense
that our intelligence is kind of limited there are many things for which we do their own.
Their own decision
and it's true also of animals like why is it that animals some animals have much larger brains than we do
and they're not that smart.
And you know you could come up with a bunch of reasons but it's not the you have a bigger brain right so
and their brain like mammals brain is very very close to ours. So there's it's hard to say now.
I think it's fair to consider the worse scenarios and to study it
and have you know people really seriously considering what could happen
and how we could prevent any dangerous thing I think it's actually important that some people do that
but right now I see this is a very long term potential
and the most plausible scenario is not that according to my vision. Notes.
You're right that I think we are more afraid of things we don't understand.
And scientists who are working with the planning every day. Don't feel.
That they have anything to fear because they can think they understand what's going on in the can see clearly that
there is no danger and that's foreseeable. So you're right that's part of it.
There's the psychology of seeing the machine as some other being there's the lack of knowledge there is the influence
of science fiction so all of these factors come together
and also the fact that the technology has been making a lot of privacy recently. So all of that I think.
Creates a kind of exaggerated fear. I'm not saying we should have any fear. I'm just saying it's exaggerated right now.
Well. It may part of life or you are you. You are. You do. I'm thinking all the time.
Yes and whether I'm thinking on the things that matter to me the most maybe not enough.
Managing a being in situ to have a lot of students and so on means my time is this person but when I can you know.
Focus or when I am. You know in a scientific discussion with people and so on.
Of course there's a lot of thinking and it's really important. That's how we move forward.
Now you know with me first which you know I was. He was yes you know we were yeah so. So our fingers so. So what.
What happens. OK yes.
So when I listen to somebody explaining something maybe one of my students talking about an experiment
or another researcher talking about their idea. Something builds up in my mind trying to understand what is going on.
And that's already thinking but then.
Things happen so other pieces of information and or standing connect to this and I see some flaw
or some some some connection. And and that's that's where the creativity of creativity comes in and.
I have the impulse of talking about it and that's just one turn in a discussion.
And we go like this and new ideas spring like this and it's very very rewarding. Well I yes.
Yes it is possible not to think it's hard. But if you really you know.
If you really relax
or you are experiencing something very intensely then you're you're not you're not into your thoughts here you're into
just the some. Present time experience. Yes Like for example. Yes.
But thinking isn't just rational a lot of it is I don't mean it's irrational
but it's a lot of the thinking is something that happens.
Somehow behind the scenes that has to do with intuition that has to do with.
Ideologies and it's not necessarily A causes B. Causes C.
It's not the kind of logical thinking that's going on in my mind.
Most of the time it's much softer and that's why we need the Matthew noted. To filter and fine tune the ideas.
But the raw thinking is very.
The fuzzy and but it's very rich because it's connecting a lot of things together and it's discovering the.
Consistencies that allow us to move to the next stage and solve problems. Are you.
You're in THE SITUATION when you think it happens to me. I used to spend some time meditating.
And there you learn to pay attention to your own thoughts.
So it does happen to me it happens to me also that I get so immersed in my thoughts in ordinary daily activities that
people thought I think that I'm very distracted and not present and they can be offended.
But it's not always like that sometimes I'm actually very very present.
I can be very very present to some somebody talking to me.
And that's really important for what I have my job right because. If I listen to somebody.
In a way that's not complete.
I can't really understand fully and participate in in a rich exchange focused on you know you are this problem
and you think. Yeah. Your situation with people emotionally of you ride like yes you were yes yes.
There's something you decide. People focus or how do you write. That's right. So. I write I have some notebooks.
I write my ideas.
Often when I wake up or sometimes an idea comes and I want to write it down like if I was afraid of losing it.
But actually the good ideas they don't they don't go away.
Turns out very often I write them but I don't even go back to read in them.
It's just that it makes me feel better and it anchors also the fact of writing an idea kind of makes it.
Take more room in my mind. And there's also something to be said about concentration. So.
So my work because I'm immersed with so many people can be very destructive.
But to really make big progress in science. It also needs times when I can be very focused and. And where the.
The ideas about a problem in a different point of view
and all the elements sort of fill my mind I'm completely filled with this. That's where you can be really productive.
And it might take a long time before you reach that state.
Sometimes it can take years for a student to really go deep into a subject so that he can be fully immersed in it
and it.
That's when you can really start seeing through things and getting things to stand together and solidly
and now you can you can extend science right now when things are solid in your mind you can move forward.
Yeah other this when that
when you need enough concentration on something to really truly get these these moves then there's the other mode of
thinking which is the brainstorming mode where out of the blue I started this question five minutes later something
comes up. So that's more like random and it's also very you can be very.
Productive as well it depends on the stimulation from someone else so someone introduces a problem.
And immediately I gather something comes up and we have maybe an exchange.
So that's more superficial but a lot of good things come out of that exchange because of that
and the brainstorming whereas the other there is the other mode of thinking which is I'm alone. Nobody bothers me.
Nobody is asking for my attention I'm walking.
I'm How office leap and there I can fully concentrate eyes closed
or not really paying attention to what's going on in front of me because I'm completely in my thoughts. When.
So the time when the two times when I spend more. On this consider it.
Thinking is usually when I wake up and when I'm walking back and forth between home and university. What happens. Well.
So I emerge to consciousness like everybody does every morning and eyes close and so on and.
Some some thought related to a research question or maybe not a research question comes up and
and if I'm interested in it. I started like going deeper into it. And still my eyes closed and.
And then it's like if you. You see. A thread dangling and you pull on it then more stuff comes down.
And you see more things and you pull more and likes. It's an avalanche of things coming right.
So the more you you you you pull on those strings and the more new things go on or information comes together
and sometimes it goes nowhere and sometimes as hard new ideas come about. You. I can stay like this for an hour. Yeah.
Yeah yeah.
Often what happens is I see something I haven't seen before and I get too excited so that Weeks me up
and I want to write it down so I have my notebook that far and I write it down
or I want to send an email to somebody saying oh I thought about this and it's like six in the morning in there
and they wonder if I'm working all the time. So you work. Oh yeah oh you're right.
Yeah well so once I have I'm writing it down my eyes are open and. And it's like I'm I feel relieved. Right.
It's like OK now. Now I can go and maybe have breakfast or take a shower or something. So having written it down.
And it might take some time to write it down.
Also sometimes I write an email and it's longer and now that the act of writing it is a different thing.
So there's initial sort of spark of vision which is still very fuzzy but then
when you have to communicate the idea to someone else.
So you can email you have to really make a different kind of effort you realize some flaws in your initial ideas
and you have to clean it up in make sure it's and or stand and it now takes a different form. And and.
Sometimes you realize when you do it that it was. Nothing really. Yeah I was just have to remember you know. What.
I dinners and of course the. Something she's fine with.
I think she she's glad to see this these kind of thing happened she is.
She's happy for me that I live these very rewarding moments. But what happens you know. I mean I tell her.
Often though I just had an idea. I want to say. Just one. What I mean the science.
Yes or no but Chander stance that is really important for me and this is how I move forward and my work
and also how emotionally. Fulfilling it is. OK. Yes let's talk about what you. Yes yes.
So so that walk is you can really think of it as a kind of meditation. So you know what you want you know.
So every day I walk up the hail from my home to the university and it's about half an hour
and that's always the same path.
And because I know this path so well I don't have to really pay much attention to what's going on
and I can just relax and let thoughts. Go by and eventually focus on something. Or not sometimes just.
Many more in the evening where I'm tired. Maybe you just the way to relax and. Let's go let's go. Yes absolutely.
Because I'm not bombarded by. The outside world. I can just sense. Yeah but. I kind of ignore that. You work.
So when I was young I used to. Hit my head on. Yeah yeah or reading while walking.
No Well actually it does now because I sometimes I check my my phone see lots of people do that not being paying
attention to what's going on. But yeah yeah. That's nice metaphor.
Oh this route situation where you have some really good ideas. I would have some memories of. CITIC moments going up.
Thinking about some of the ideas and that have been.
Going through my mind over the last year in particular because these are more recent memories. So right right.
So as I said earlier it's like if the rest of the world is in a haze. Right.
It's like there is automatic control of the walking and. Watching for other people in cars potentially.
But but I like is that you had a three D.
Projection of my thoughts in front of me that are taking most of the room and
and I I might thinking works a lot by visualization and I think a lot of people like that.
It's a very nice tool that we have using or kind of visual analogies to.
And
or stand things even if it's not a faithful portrait of what's going on the visual analogies are really helping me at
least to make sense of things.
So it's like if I had pictures in my mind to illustrate what's going on and it's like I see little. You know.
What I see I see information flow in neural networks.
It's like if I was running a simulation in my mind of what would happen if some rule of conduct was followed by by a
you know in this algorithm in this process when you. Yeah yeah.
So so it's like if I was running a computer simulation in my mind to try to figure out.
What would happen if some if I made such choices
or if we consider such equation in what would it entail what would happen. Imagine different situations and.
Of course it's not as detailed if we as if we do the a real computer simulation.
But it provides a lot of insight for what's going on. Yet. Well so I remember a particular moment.
I was walking on the north sidewalk of Queen Mary Street
and I was seeing the big church we have there which is called the or at it's beautiful and.
And then I got this inside the boat perch of Asians. Propagating in chains.
From the beginning or just the last sentence. And so then I got this insight.
As visually of these approaches happening on neurons that propagate to other neurons and provided to other neurons
and it was like something like I'm doing with my hands but it was like something visual. And then suddenly I had.
The thought that this this could this could work that this could explain things that I was trying to understand. I did.
Great. I think of all the good feelings that we can have in life. Though the feeling we get when.
Something clicks the year Rica.
Is probably maybe the strongest and most powerful than one that we can seek again and again
and only brings positive things.
Maybe you know stronger than food and sex and its usual good things we get from from our experience.
This kind of what these kinds of moments. Provide pleasure. It's a different kind of pleasure.
Just like you know different pleasures a different sensory pleasure.
And so on but it's really like I think you know when your brain realizes something understand something.
It's like you are send yourself some some molecules to me Ward you say oh great do it again if you can't write it again.
Yeah yeah that's that's my job. So this is one moment at the church was it was a huge now.
Nothing to do with I don't believe in God. But. Yeah if I don't leave. I do but if you think of gold as.
Someone who created us and is our example. Yes. Trying to understand what's happening in your head will us.
Isn't that what other people call God. I'm not sure I understand your question. When you understand how brain works.
Yes you understand. When we understand how brains work we understand who we are. To some extent.
I mean every person part of us. That's one of my motivations.
And the process of doing it is something that defines us individually but also as a collective as a group and society.
So there may be some connections to religion which are about connecting us to some extent. You know. Really you know.
So sometimes I think it's too short but then you know have things to do so you know or yeah yeah.
I feel so I'm going uphill my body is working hard. I mean I'm not running but I'm walking and I can feel the muscles.
Warming up and.
My whole body becoming more forward energy and I think that helps the brain as well as how it feels in the way. Most.
Right yes. When I go up hill I see the university but.
But there is something that's related to your question which is you know each time I have these insights these eureka
moments. It's like seeing the promised land. It's very much like that.
It's like you have a glimpse of something you had never seen before and it looks great
and you feel like you now see a path to go there.
So I think it's very very close to this idea of seeing the promised land.
But of course it's not just one promised land.
It's one step to you know the next valley in the next valley and that's how we climb really you know big mountains so.
We don't really know. You know by. Maybe just a few. So what you're going to do. What are you ready.
So Friday I'm going to make a presentation to the rest of the researchers in the lab in the institute.
About one of the topics most excited about these days.
Which is trying to bridge the gap between what we do in machine learning what has to which has to do with AI
and building intelligent machines and in the brain.
I'm not really a brain expert I'm more a machine learning person but I talk to your scientists and so on and I try
and really care about. The big question of how is the brain doing the really complex things that it does.
And so the work I'm going to tell you.
About Friday is one of small step in that direction that we've achieved in the last few months. Yes exactly.
That's right. And I being making those small steps you know on this particular topic for for about a year and a half.
So it's not like just something happens and you are there right. It's a lot of in insides that need human and.
Get understanding and. Science makes progress steps. Most of those steps are small some are slightly bigger.
Seen from the outside. Sometimes people have the impression.
Oh there's this big breakthrough breakthrough enjoy is like to talk about breakthrough breakthrough break Richter
but actually science is very very progressive because we gradually understand better the world.